[Musique]
les premiers travaux ont commencé il ya
tout juste cinq ans la traversée de
cette ravine des plaines à saint-paul
aura nécessité la réalisation de cet
ouvrage d'art d'exception de plus de 100
mètres de portée baptisé air d2 d4
ce pont facilite le maillage routier
entre les hauts et les bas de saint paul
et fait la liaison entre la route
départementale 2 et la route
départementale 4 donc ce qu'on appelle
la route de bois neuf salles qui part de
savannah dans les bas de la route
nationale et qui dessert tous les hauts
de saint paul la plaine au bois de
nèfles bellemène etc
donc c'est l'objectif est de relier
cette route là à la rd2 donc c'est une
route qui part de cambaie et qui
s'arrêtent au niveau de la rive droite
de la rabine la plaine c'est en présence
des co financeurs du chantier l'état la
région et le département de la réunion
que s'est fait l'inauguration de cette
liaison pour un montant global de 20
millions d'euros hors taxes ce projet
structurant améliorera la fluidification
de la circulation entre les quartiers
des hauts de saint paul et 20 voitures
par jour qui descendent des ovaires
savannah c'est énorme
et quand on voit les constructions qui
continue il y en aura encore de plus en
plus et ce pauvre il arrive à point et
aussi pour les habitants des hauts ce
sera un accès plus facile pour aller
travailler
ceux qui descendent vers la route
nationale pour les travailler vers le
pauvre ça denis vers saint paul pourront
passer par ici et ça sera aussi un
soulagement pour les habitants de sans
souci parce que voyez vous ici pas trop
loin d'ici là des familles qui habitent
propos de la route le chemin lambert à
son souci est bien les voitures
passeront perd peut-être ces cases ça
sera bien près de quinze mille véhicules
emprunteront chaque jour cette vidéo
routière avec une croissance moyenne du
flux d'automobilistes de près de 4%
chaque année sabieh on répond à une
attente forte des habitants de la zone
[Musique]